Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Meric Aydonat
Her şey 1986 yılında Roma’da başladı.
İspanyol basamaklarının bulunduğu
simgesel bir meydanda,
uluslararası bir fast food zinciri
bir restoran açmak istedi.
Ama İtalyanlar - halk - hayır dedi.
Bizim mutfağımız dünyanın en ünlü,
en iyi mutfaklarından biridir.
Bizim pizzamız var, makarnamız var,
şarabımız var, peynirimiz var,
etimiz var, her şeyimiz var.
Sen bu meydanda bizi -dünyanın her yerinde
tadı aynı olan- fastfoodla tanıtamazsın,
bize bunu sunamazsın diye
protesto düzenlemeye başladılar
Carlo Petrini önderliğinde.
Ve meydanlara dev kazanlar kurdular,
makarna pişirdiler,
dağıttılar ve kazandılar.
O restoran açılmadı.
Bu zaferden, bu dik duruştan
yavaş hareketi başladı diyebiliriz:
Slowfood kuruldu.
Slowfood şu an dünyada yüz binin üzerinde
gönüllüsü, üyesi olan bir örgüt.
Slowfood, cittaslow, yavaş şehir, yavaş
medya, yavaş mimari, yavaş tarım…
Herkes dünyayı bir ucundan tutup
yavaşlatmaya çalışmaya başladı.
Nasıl yavaş yaşayabiliriz peki?
Ben bugün bunu beş perspektifte
anlatmak istiyorum:
Üreterek, mutlu olarak,
geleneklerimize ve tarihimize
sahip çıkarak.
O an orada olarak.
Üretmek.
Üretmek aslında insanın
en büyük meziyetlerinden biri.
Aklımızı, elimizi, vücudumuzu kullanarak
inanılmaz şeyler yapabiliyoruz.
Bu binayı yapmışız.
Bu bina bir yana piramitleri yapmışız.
Yüzyıllardır okunan kitaplar yazmışız.
Dinleyince insanın
böyle içini kıpırdatan
müzik eserleri bestelemişiz.
Resimler yapmışız.
Üretebiliyoruz ve muhteşem
şeyler yapabiliyoruz.
Her ne kadar şu anda toplumda
en önemli şey para harcamak,
tüketmek gibi gözüksede
biz insan olarak aslında
bundan çok daha fazlasıyız.
Nasıl üretebiliriz?
Hiçbir şey yapamıyorsak
balkonda domates yetiştirebiliriz.
Balkonda domates yetiştirmek
nasıl bir üretmek?
Bize nasıl bir faydası olacak?
Üretmenin mutluluğuna sahip olacağız.
Tüketimimizi azaltacak.
Bir de bir yandan, belki de en önemlisi,
üretilen bir şeyin değerini
daha iyi anlayacağız.
Saksı aldık, toprak derken yerel bir
domatesin tohumunu bulduk,
diktik.
Suladık her gün.
Büyüdü, fide haline geldi.
Küçük domatesleri görmeye başladık,
onlar büyüdü.
Derken bir sabah kahvaltıya oturmadan
gittik bir tane kopardık,
kestik.
Mis gibi tat, inanılmaz bir koku…
İlaçsız, hormonsuz bir domates…
Biz onu marketten de alabilirdik.
Ama bu mutluluğa, bu üretmenin
gururuna kavuşamazdık.
Peki israfı nasıl engelleyecek bu?
Açık büfede olduğunuzu düşünün.
Açık büfe deyip küçümsememek lazım.
Açık büfe aslında bir er meydanı,
muazzam bir kişilik ve karakter sınavı.
İşte bir konferansa gidiyorsunuz.
Sürdürülebilirlik, yeşil ekonomi,
güneş panelleri…
Öğlen; elimizde tabak bir bakıyoruz
on tane köfte, buradan bir
sucuk kulesi çıkmış,
zemin pilavla güçlendirilmiş,
hala dolma tıkmaya çalışıyoruz oraya.
Yiyecek miyiz?
İmkânı yok, o kadar bir tabak dolusu
yemeği yememize imkan yok.
Niye alıyoruz?
Hem çok var hem aramızda
bir duygusal bağ yok.
Alırız; yersek yeriz, yemezsek atarız.
Ama kendi domatesimizi ‘’Ben buradan
iki tane koparayım, yemezsem atarım.’’
diyemiyoruz.
İşte üretilen bir şeyin, bir ürünün,
değerini daha iyi anlıyoruz diyebilirim.
Sosyalleşmek çok önemli bir şey.
Bence sosyalleşmenin
en iyi imkanlarından biri; sofra.
Yemek yemek.
Çünkü yemek yemek
sadece ayakta atıştırılan
bir kalori alımı değildir.
Ritüel bir tören;
ailemizden bizlere aktarılmış,
onların büyüklerinden onlara aktarılmış
bir etkinlik, sosyalleşme etkinliği,
bir fırsat.
Şöyle de yemek yiyebiliriz tabi:
Bir alışveriş merkezine gittik.
Kapalı alan, havasız,
floresan ışıklar,
fonda saçma sapan bir müzik çalıyor.
Gittik x menüsü büyük seçim,
üç dakika içinde yemeğimiz geldi.
Üç dakikada(!) yani üç dakikada
yemek gelebilir mi?
Hazırlanabilir mi gerçek yemek?
İmkanı yok.
Önümüze geldi.
Bir gıda geldi, yedik.
Çatalsız bıçaksız, tatsız tutsuz
yedik ve gittik.
Bir de şöyle yemek
yediğimizi düşünelim:
Evdeyiz.
Sevdiklerimiz var.
Birlikte yemek yapıyoruz.
Yalnız, yaptığımız yemek
gerçek bir yemek.
Yani öyle fabrikadan çıkmış,
paketli, işte şu kadarcık harflerle
dört parmak içindekiler
yazan bir yemek değil.
Gerçek bir yemek.
İçinde ne olduğunu biliyoruz
çünkü içini biz koyuyoruz.
Bir yandan konuşuyoruz
yemek hazırlarken:
‘’Aa sen buna sarımsak mı koydun?
Aa bizimkiler Girit’ten gelmiş,
her şeye sarımsak koyar.’’
Paylaşmaya başlıyoruz.
Birbirimizi daha iyi tanımaya başlıyoruz
ve oturunca da sofraya; ‘’Bugün ne yaptın?
Yarın ne yapacaksın?
Kendini nasıl hissediyorsun?’’
İnanılmaz bir paylaşım ortamı,
sosyalleşme ortamı.
Aslında yemek yemek bu.
Sadece gıda alayım, kalori alayım değil.
Birlikte paylaşabileceğimiz bir sofra var.
Orada oturup paylaşmamız gerekiyor.
Gelenekler, görenekler,
tarihimiz, bizi nasıl yavaşlatabilir?
Şöyle bir örnek vermek istiyorum ona.
İzmir’de mesela Hıdırellez kutlarız.
İşte o akşam herkes hayalini,
umudunu bir kâğıda yazar,
gülün dibine gömer, denize atar.
Sahilde ateşler yakılır,
üzerinden atlanır.
Bu bize ne katıyor?
Tanımadığımız insanlarla birlikte o an
orada; daha iyi bir yaşam için,
daha iyi bir yıl için bir aradayız.
Herkesin yüzünde bir gülümseme…
Zaten Anadolu’da, Mezopotamya’da,
Orta Asya’da kim bilir kaç bin yıldır,
kim bilir başka nerelerde
kutlanan bir etkinlik:
Bahara merhaba.
Şimdi bunun bize, toplumumuza
kattığı inanılmaz bir değer var.
Bir birliktelik,
hoşgörü ve ortaklık
duygusu sağlıyor bize.
Biz bu etkinliğe geleneğe göre
sadece Hıdırellez değil,
daha birçok böyle geleneğimiz var.
Kaybettiğimiz anda hiçbir zaman
eskisi kadar mutlu olamayacağız.
Toplumumuzda her zaman
bir şeyler eksik olmuş olacak.
Mesela bu içinde yaşadığımız şehir:
Ne zaman yapılmış?
Kimler yaşamış?
Her gün önünden geçtiğimiz
o han, ne zaman yapılmış?
Neden yapılmış?
Ne işe yaramış?
Bunları bilmemiz lazım.
Bunları bilmemizin sebebi
aslında nostaljik, bir duygusallık,
geçmişe gidelim, at arabası
kullanalım değil.
Bunları bilmemizin sebebi; bu şehrin bir
kimliği, kültürü, bir ruhu var.
Ve bu ruhun bize kattığı birçok şey var.
Mesela yine İzmir’den bir örnek vereyim.
İzmir’de balkon kültürü vardır.
Yazın balkon yıkanır, hava serinler.
Çıkarsınız, oturursunuz
bir yemek yersiniz,
komşuya yemek ikram edersiniz.
"Aa merhaba!’’ dersiniz
sokağın karşısında oturan komşunuza.
‘’Aa Almancı yeni araba almış,
bilmem neler taşınmış.’’
Yani bütün toplumla iç içesiniz.
Kamusal bir alan aslında o balkon.
Şimdi o ne oluyor?
Kentsel dönüşümle aslında
buna biz neden oluyoruz biraz da.
Balkonları kapıyoruz.
Balkonları kapıyoruz
salonumuz büyüsün diye.
Evet salonumuz büyüyor ama
aslında kendi yaşamımız küçülüyor.
Toplumla iletişim haline girdiğimiz,
herkesi tanımasak da
aşina olduğumuz
bir yaşam alanını yok ediyoruz.
Şimdi bunu bilmezsek
buna sahip de çıkamayız,
bunu da koruyamayız.
Ve bunu kaybedince
çok fazla şey kaybetmiş oluyoruz.
O an orada olmak demiştik.
O an orada olmak ne demek?
Mesela salonumuzda
çocuğumuzla oynuyoruz.
Balkonu da kapadık.
İyice geniş bir ortam, çok mutluyuz.
Bir yandan gözümüz televizyonda.
İşte maç kaç kaç olmuş, o beş saat
süren diziyi aman kaçırmayayım diye
bir yandan ona bakıyoruz.
Ya da arkadaşlarımızla dışarı çıktık.
Güleceğiz, eğleneceğiz
ama elimizde telefon
tweet mi geldi, kaç like aldım,
mail mi geldi, ne oldu?
Sürekli ona bakıyoruz.
O an orada değiliz.
Kafamız başka bir yerde.
Nasıl fiziksel olarak ben
hem orada hem burada olamıyorsam;
zihinsel olarak da iki yerde olamıyoruz.
O yüzden yaşadığımız anda
olmamız gerekiyor.
Yaşadığımız anı
deneyimlememiz,yaşamamız,
hissetmemiz gerekiyor.
Bu sadece güzel bir şey gibi
kulağa gelebiliyor.
Aslında bu bilimsel bir gerçek.
Psikolojide, terapide
kullanılan bir teknik.
Çok fazla geçmişe takılıyorsak,
depresif oluyoruz.
Olabiliriz daha doğrusu.
Ya da geleceği çok fazla kafamıza taktık,
düşünüyoruz sürekli.
Daha kaygılı, daha stresli
bir insan olabiliyoruz.
Aslında çok basit.
Bizim olmamız gereken yer burası.
Kafamızda bütün benliğimizle
bu anı yaşamamız gerekiyor.
Beni aslında bunların yanı sıra
en çok yavaşlatan şey
1985 model bir araba oldu.
Hem zihinsel olarak
hem fiziksel olarak yavaşlattı.
Bir arabamız vardı.
Çocuğumuz oldu.
Bir araba daha almamız gerekti.
Çok para da harcamak istemiyorum.
Tüketime karşıyım ama almam gerekiyor.
1985 model bir araba buldum.
Aldım.
En büyük korkum aslında biraz şeydi;
trafikte ben biraz
trafik canavarı oluyorum.
Onu sollayım, bunu sağlayım,
o beni geçti, ben onu geçeceğim,
hızlı gideyim,
ona korna, buna korna…
İnanılmaz stresli!
Memnun da değilim bundan,
mutlu da değilim.
Bu şekilde araba kullanıyorum.
Dedim şimdi bu arabayı alacağım,
iyice yavaş, iyice gerileceğim
iyice stres olacağım,
yetişemeyeceğim diye.
Ama çok değişik bir şey oldu.
Arabayı kullanıyorum, hiçbir stres yok.
İnanılmaz rahatım.
Kolumu çıkarıyorum, müziği açıyorum.
O beni geçmiş, ben onu geçmişim
hiç umurumda değil.
Diğer arabayla, hızlı giden bir arabayı
kullandığım zaman içimden
trafik canavarı çıkıyorsa
bu arabayı kullanırken
sanki Marmaris’te tekne turunda
tekne kullanıyormuşum gibi
böyle bir rahatlık, bir gevşeklik.
Çok mutluyum.
Dedim yani ne olabilir?
Bu ikisi arasında bu fark nasıl olabilir?
O an anladım ki; hızlı gitme
potansiyeli olan bir araba kullanırken
toplum, sistem, yaşam,
adına ne derseniz deyin,
bir şekilde hızlandırıyor sizi.
Acele et, çabuk ol,
o seni geçti sen onu geç…
Ama yavaş bir araba kullanınca
teknik olarak hızlı gidemeyeceğim için,
bu baskı üzerimden kalkıyor.
Otomatikman yavaş gitmek
zorunda kalıyorum.
Bu aslında yaşamda da böyle.
İstesek de istemesek de
farkında olmasak
da bir şekilde hızlanıyoruz.
Daha çok çalış, daha çok para kazan.
İşte o telefon almış sen de al,
o arabasını yenilemiş sen de yenile.
Çabuk, çabuk, çabuk…
Ama yavaş da yaşasak
hızlı da yaşasak
sonuçta varacağımız nokta aynı.
Aynı yere geliyoruz
ve sınırlı bir süremiz var.
Bu sınırlı sürede mutlu olmak,
daha yavaş yaşamak,
daha iyi bir yaşam sürmek elimizde.
Peki niye öyle yapmıyoruz?
Yani şu yaşadığımız gün
bir daha asla geri gelmeyecek.
Şu saniye gitti bitti.
Bu sınırlı süremizi daha iyi yaşayalım,
daha iyi bir dünya kurabilir miyiz,
daha mutlu olabilir miyiz? Derken;
2011 yılında "Yavaş Yaşamı
Destekleme Derneğini" kurduk.
Amacımız biraz naif, biraz çocuksu,
ütopik, daha iyi bir yaşam
kurmak istiyoruz.
Daha mutlu bir yaşam kurmak istiyoruz.
Bizce de bunun yolu, çözümü, yavaşlamak.
Biraz yavaşlayalım.
Daha az tüketelim, daha çok üretelim.
Bunu yapmaya çalışıyoruz çünkü
bu şekilde hızlı yaşadığımız
sürece kendimizi,
zamanımızı ve bütün dünyayı,
aslında hayatı, tüketiyoruz.
O yüzden biraz daha yavaşlamak elimizde.
Bunun için çalışıyoruz.
Yapılabilecek çok şey var bu konuda.
Sadece burada bahsettiklerim
birer şahsi örnek.
Geri dönüşüm yapılabilir,
bir şey bozulunca atmak yerine
tamir edilebilir.
Minimalist yaklaşımlar var;
çok az eşya sahip olma hakkında,
yapılabilecek çok şey var
ve bunlar çok basit şeyler:
domates üretmek.
Bunlar basit, yapılabilecek şeyler.
Daha iyi, daha yavaş
bir dünya geçekten mümkün.
Buna inanmamız lazım.
Siz de bir tarafından tutup,
dünyayı yavaşlatmamıza
yardımcı olursanız çok seviniriz.
Teşekkürler…
(Alkışlar)